two two sillier show inspired questions
for you right now
so
you two are stan are stranded on a
deserted island and you stumble upon a
bunker that's filled with food i know
you guys aren't jerks that are going to
take the food for yourself
but
you get if there's one bit of food in
that bunker that's like your favorite
thing in the world that you're going to
pocket and hide from the group what is
it um tacos to
madre in l.a
that yeah okay they did it
okay well
the error of your ways has been revealed
they do this i just got here today and
as soon as i finish this thing i'm going
to tacos de madre even though i have a
per diem for this hotel i'm going to
taco you know what i'm getting they do
this breakfast burrito and it's the most
[ __ ] up mexican
american like you can't believe it's
mexico it's just amazing okay it's got
it's got scrambled egg it's got truffled
aioli you get it with uh this chili
fried chicken it's like sweet but it's
chicken it's chicken fried chicken in
the burrito american cheese okay hash
brown
and then
chipotle aioli through that thing that's
in the bunker i'm big on crunchy soft
and if i went into that bunker i'll tell
you what be going on there'd be a tacos
to madre stand and they'd have
ingredients to make one burrito i'd go
down that hat he'd whip that bad boy up
he'd give it to me hot and fresh off the
platter and then he'd pack up shop and
get in a jet and go and i would i would
feast on that i wouldn't hide it i'd eat
that [ __ ] all of it all the way i didn't
mention it in fact i would tell everyone
about it i wouldn't hide it why would i
hide the best food in the world
did not know that they were getting a
plug but they're getting one to that big
old creep that follows that and goes to
that place after this i need some tacos
in my life yeah
i was just gonna say um uh
red strawberry licorice that isn't
twisted
you couldn't have given a more polar
opposite example
all right one more one more sillier one
for you guys
so i'm not one to judge impressions or
accents or anything like that but can
either of you do an impression that's
better than your luigi impression in the
show well i can do a pretty good uh
scottish accent i think if you know uh
onions
you're from london
yep
that's mine all right i approve
all right let's get into the show now so
charles this is your first big role in a
tv show so two-parter for you here
what's something about you know things
that happened when you hit the wild set
that made you think to yourself like yes
i have this i am made for this but then
on the other hand what's something that
you know required a little bit of a
learning curve that you know now you
learned and you can take on to future
projects
right ah when we shot the video clip in
episode six i'd be you know we we we've
been going for a while so i kind of knew
how everything worked and felt
comfortable
um but this was like the first moment
where it was it was just me and none of
my other cast members but i had 120
extras and we'd done this rehearsal two
different rehearsals with the dance
coordinator who was amazing name's kate
she had just come off elvis and so she
did all the dance choreo for like
hundreds of extras so i was just like oh
my god star struck even though i don't
even know who you are but you're
obviously very legit and um then we turn
up on the day and it's like you know
they're filming everything you've gotta
like
move through and and and do coordinated
dance and lip sync at the same time and
all the same time you're there with
all these extras and i've never worked
with extras before and
they were all just so excited to have a
really good time but once we got through
the first section of the video they just
were like okay and now everybody dance
and just have fun
and none of this made it into the into
the into the final edit but we did this
we just started like dancing around like
a mob and stuff like that and then like
i got one of the other dancers who i
knew was really good and i threw him in
and then he started like break dancing
and jumping all over the place
everyone's like screaming going nuts and
the camera guys doing all this [ __ ] and
like everyone's it was just like
we just like ran with it and then uh i
just felt like so uninhibited and
excited to just be doing it i wasn't
even thinking about the camera or
anything
and then when that was over we were like
walking to the next part of the video
and i was like
wow
i'm really doing what i'm supposed to be
doing i love i love my job i would do my
job every day if i could
um and yeah it's just like honor
privilege grateful i'm sitting here i'm
looking at the hollywood sign i just got
off the plane from australia i just am
just like
it's a dream come true it's a dream come
true i don't think i have time to tell
you about the [ __ ] that i i didn't feel
like
i enjoyed i honestly like any challenge
all i would say about that is any
challenge i had i was just took it as a
learning experience and i was like cool
i know where i need to improve and uh
and i and luckily i had people around me
alex a lot more experienced than i and
we were very grew very close alex's
alex is my best friend and um and you
know i had him to turn to when i felt
you know a little lost or a little like
ah like this is a bit out of my depth
here
um and and i i came out of every every
experience uh on the set and off uh
feeling
proud that i'd given it my best so that
was good
what a beautiful answer i love that all
right so
leaning into your experience alex uh how
did the wilds compare to the society was
there anything about having your first
big role on a tv series with that that
you found coming in handy on this
just the same as filming anything you
know like i i felt like i knew what to
expect which was uh far more comforting
than i remember feeling going into the
society uh and also you know like uh for
for myself like in terms of how i
approach work it's like how
how do i prepare and you know what do i
feel like i need on like a day you know
like that was that's basically it um the
the rest is just like
it's all new you know and it's very fun
and it's very cool all right i'm gonna
sneak in one spoiler question before
they kick me out of here for you alex so
you could talk about this freely we'll
save it for later but
very the very end of the show that is an
extremely charged grin that you give the
camera there and you know i know you
probably
probably don't know what lies ahead for
the character but just to be able to
play that moment for yourself what's
going through his head what what is
inspiring that grin in that moment
you know i have
we originally wrote that to be
much more relaxed he had his feet up on
the table and we filmed that version but
then we also like put this in the can as
well and then
i mean i was so
elated to see that they went with this
one i think it's a much more powerful
way to end the series than like that
that more casual approach because he
seems like he has so much more purpose
in i think like there's so much going on
and that fourth wall break it just like
really really tickled me in such a good
way so
yeah i was i was really happy and in
terms of like what's what's to come i
have no
i have no idea uh
yeah
i don't i don't know
who this person really is like we were
kind of really just uncovering who seth
is
for for me as well you know um just kind
of and i think maybe even for seth like
he doesn't have his he's probably
surprising himself with every crazy
thing that he does he's like wow i'm
capable of
some awful [ __ ] so
how'd we end up here yeah really
um i have to let you guys go but huge
congratulations on the show enjoy ellie
while you're here thank you thank you
you